Corie asks when it comes to weaknesses
within yourself how do you determine
whether to delegate or the strength
quarry I love this question because I
really don't know the full answer and
I'm not sure anybody does I think that's
a question that we all have to answer
for ourselves you know I always talk
about betting on strengths but there's
clearly been weaknesses that I've
created at least a nice baseline
foundation as a matter of fact one of
the weaknesses I've been working on for
the last thirty six months especially in
building Vayner and and I give AJ my
brother a lot of credit for this is
leading with a little bit more reality
than over honeying the situation I'm
such a positive dude that a lot of times
I don't think I was clear enough with
negative feedback or critical feedback
to an employee or a teammate because I
was hedging to mother like you're the
best this is all great don't worry but
maybe you should you know it I've been a
little bit more direct and that's a
weakness that I've that I've
strengthened no question about it
because I thought it was important
because I felt like was a couple inches
off and just by moving it a little bit
does that mean that I'm like the like
scary guy in the bill I mean I'm like
the least scary guy in the building
outside of the reputation of Who I am or
or being the CEO of a company but like
once people get to know me a little bit
like like I'm the pushover that way
because I am positive but I think that
look I would say this is an 80/20 rule
answer to me I truly still believe
minimally that you need to spend 80% of
your time on your strengths and if you
want to allocate 20% of your time to
audit you know I would actually just do
a whole lot of listening right I would
actually ask the people you work with
the people that work for you the people
you work for your friends and
contemporaries the people that are
closest to you the ten closest people to
you friends and relatives on what they
think you could work on they're a mirror
to that you may take a step back it
might hurt you've got to roll with
humility and empathy if you want to
address this and then you could start
addressing those twenty percent because
a lot of times the reason we can't
address something is because we can't
see it and the best way to see it is
through other people's eyes and then use
it you know it's funny the best way to
see it is to use your own ears actually
it's kind of an interesting there's
something there indeed we need to go a
long form on that and then and that's
that
oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe